muchísimas gracias bibiana bueno pues yo
pienso que este esta dominación y esta
confirmación puede ser considerada como
una victoria pre electoral del
presidente de un matrón y es un tema
menos en la agenda política de los eeuu
a las elecciones que una agenda que está
colapsando obviamente por el coni 1912
publicado el primer golpe y no importa
qué partido gane en 3 de noviembre con
esta fuerza los republicanos han hecho
una inversión a largo plazo en el
destino político social de los eeuu por
una sencilla razón los jueces son
vitalicios y algo muy importante que
implica esta nominación y esta
confirmación es que las elecciones de
los estados unidos probablemente serán
las más criticadas este año cuando
tomamos en cuenta los esfuerzos que se
han hecho para desconocer la
credibilidad del sistema de voto a
través del correo electrónico reo postal
y sobre todo cuando no hemos visto una
clara convicción del presidente de que
piensa de que piensa reconocerlos
los resultados de estas elecciones como
ya lo hemos visto en los diferentes
debates donde ha sido incapaz de hacer
esto cuando nosotros vemos el perfil
académico e ideológico de esta fuerza de
amy y johnny pérez
podríamos decir que esto tiene mucho
potencial para afectar las decisiones
relacionadas con inmigración las
decisiones relacionadas con la familia
una litigación incluso por la
presidencia de los eeuu y bueno
posiciones en el senado quizás sea el as
bajo la manga que trump tiene para
invalidar el obamacare o para invalidar
otros temas de la agenda política del
gobierno anterior bueno pero cuéntenos
justamente usted hablaba de ese tema y
es que este proceso de confirmación tuvo
fuertes tintes políticos pues se dio en
medio de una elección presidencial que
ya estaba en curso con el voto
anticipado y vemos que el voto para
confirmar a la jueza fue casi totalmente
partidista cree usted que dividir a esto
aún más el nombre abierto este
nombramiento y vivirá aún más a los
estadounidenses en un país que ya está
polarizado sin duda en este proceso
tenemos que decir que los republicanos
tenían mucho que ganar los demócratas
mucho que perder me explico había una
diferencia de 654 en cuanto a la
ideología conservadora y progresista en
el tribunal y ahora esta diferencia es
mucho más grande horas de 6 a 3 por lo
tanto te podría decir que el presidente
estaba
para cubrir la vacante de la jueza
guinness ver desde el primer día de su
presidencia pues sabíamos que esta
señora arrastraba unos problemas de
salud que ya todos conocíamos entonces
en el imaginario de trump perseguía la
sustituto ideal después de haberla
considerado para la vacante que se abrió
en el 2017 y que finalmente terminó en
manos de calama te podría decir también
que ver siempre estuvo en el radar del
presidente trump y bueno es una gran
oportunidad que él tiene yo diría que él
básicamente lo que ha logrado con esto
es un seguro de vida a nivel del
tribunal superior en caso de que él
tenga que litigar su propia presidencia
sabemos que la jueza que ha muerto
desvern era muy carismática y por tanto
será unos zapatos muy grandes los que
tendrá que ponerse amy con iu y de erc
pero la realidad es que esto va a tener
un efecto inmediato en las decisiones
políticas no judiciales porque también
son políticas que van a determinar el
futuro de este país específicamente los
temas como el matrimonio la familia en
general obviamente los soñadores y otros
temas tan importantes para que muchos
muchos movimientos
les perdieron una gran aliada de la
jueza anterior y han ganado una gran
barrera con una jueza nueva bueno y
entre las posibles armas de los
demócratas estaría ahora la posibilidad
de expandir la corte que tan realista o
qué tan difícil sería entonces avanzar
en un proyecto como este claro esto es
un proyecto que va a necesitar
obviamente un acuerdo o un apoyo
bipartidista a lo que me refiero con
esto es que no es tan fácil como decirlo
pero es una posibilidad los demócratas
pretenden hacerlo pretenden por lo menos
promover la idea de una reforma del
tribunal superior ya sea para aumentar
sus sus jueces para aumentar sus
miembros que hasta ahora es un total de
nueve o posiblemente para rotar estos
miembros y garantizar un balance
ideológico en este tribunal superior de
los eeuu que deciden básicamente las las
decisiones más importantes este país las
cuestiones más importantes la vida es
que este este resultado ha tenido un
efecto bastante importante en este
proceso electoral porque ahora mismo y
lo vimos cuando se anunció la muerte de
la jueza que se está reemplazando los
demócratas se movilizaron más y
empezaron a hacer más donaciones porque
precisa
saben que de esto depende el futuro de
ellos mismos el futuro de la nación
mientras que los republicanos en este
caso lo que han hecho es que se han
asegurado su futuro ideológico
independientemente del resultado del
2003 por supuesto de noviembre de el 3
de noviembre por supuesto que estas
elecciones y este proceso de nominación
y confirmación de un juez lo que ha
hecho es dividir aún más las grietas
sociales de los eeuu y por tanto será
muy interesante lo que estaremos viendo
pues es la opinión de johan y vicente
rumba er estratega político de la lista
electoral desde washington y gracias por
estar en france 24 de esta mañana